Speaker 1: OK, the arrests continue to be
made in relation to the January six Trump
riots, even though it's been 14 months and
three days since the day of the riots, we
still see arrests being made in.
Some of these are major, and the latest one
is that Proud Boys leader Enrique Tarrio has
been arrested and is under.
He was pulled out of bed.
Yes.
Boxers or briefs?
Not exactly the main question that law enforcement
was asking when they pulled him out of bed
and arrested him.
This is a this is a major, major deal.
Daily Beast reporting Proud Boys leader dragged
out of bed in his underwear to face conspiracy
charge and apparently taken by complete surprise.
Former Proud Boys ringleader Enrique Tarrio
was handcuffed and nothing but his skivvies
early Tuesday morning as police arrived at
his Miami home to arrest him for conspiracy
relating to the Jan. six insurrection.
In footage of the arrest, a 38 year old Tarrio
can be seen exiting with his house, raise
his hands, raised surrendering to police.
He wasn't at the riot, having been unavoidably
detained that is arrested two days before
for burning a stolen Black Lives Matter flag.
But the feds allege he organized alongside
five other Proud Boys members the attack on
the Capitol.
The riot was the final stage of a convoluted
plot involving a flurry of text messages,
social media posts and a meeting in a D.C.
parking garage on January 5th.
Tarrio was released from prison for the flag
burning incident two months ago.
He has now been arrested once again.
The video is pretty wild.
There's video of him being pulled out of the
house in his in his ruse, as I mentioned.
And the next thing would be, well, it would
be great if the politicians who supported
the Jan. six insurrection were treated in
the exact same way it would.
It would really be something, by the way,
to see to see Josh Hawley arrested in a diaper.
I'm sorry in his underwear.
It would really be something else, and it
would even be more interesting to see Attorney
General Merrick Garland in his pajamas, arresting
Trump, wearing wearing briefs or whatever.
In all seriousness, this Enrique Tarrio guy
is really, really not a good guy.
Now, some of you may know about the Proud
Boys, and some may not.
The Proud Boys is a far, far, far right what's
called neo fascist group by many.
It's as far as I know it's an exclusively
male organization, although it's conceivable
that I mean, I don't know how official membership
is.
Anyway, it's conceivable there may be.
There may be some women involved, to some
degree.
Tarrio specifically is Cuban-American and
Afro-Cuban ethnically, and some say, Well,
that's kind of kind of interesting that this
right wing neo fascist group allows him in
or whatever.
But yes, they as long as you are willing to
have the right views, there are a pair apparently
are no race based tests for neo fascist Proud
Boy membership, but this guy could really
be facing very, very serious penalties.
And for if the name sounds familiar, for a
year, there has been discussion of is Tarrio
going to be arrested for his role in inciting
planning whatever the January six riots?
And the answer is that indeed he has been.
And of course, when it takes this usual, from
what I've been reading and some of the lawyers
I spoke to, when things take this long, it's
because they really wait.
It's not because they wait until later investigators
for the more serious charges, it's that the
more serious charges often are more complicated
to prove and to feel good that you're ready
to charge.
And so it just takes longer to build the case.
That's what lawyers have told me.
And we will ultimately see what happens with
Tarrio, but we expected that this was potentially
coming and it now has